The arrest warrant for
Vladimir Putin issued
by the International Criminal Court
last week, was the culmination of a story
we've been following for some time.
Accusations and evidence
of the forced deportation
of thousands of Ukrainian children.
The chief prosecutor
for the ICC who brought the charges,
Karim Khan, told CNN
exclusively that these children
were treated like spoils of war.
What's more,
the Russians didn't even try to cover up
what they were doing.
Quoting the chief
prosecutor again, he said, quote,
The simple reality
that these crimes have not been hidden
CNN's David McKenzie
travel close
to the front lines
and spoke to Ukrainians
who risked their lives to try and stop
what appear to be war crimes
approaching the southern
front line in Kherson
in the liberated city.
Many have fled.
It's deceptively quiet
until the relentless terror
of
the often indiscriminate,
almost daily Russian shelling
We've come to investigate
a very deliberate horror
of the Russian occupation.
So the children who stayed
here were under five years old.
Mostly this orphanage
had more than 40 children here
Elena was a nurse here for 17 years.
Not a single child is left to start that.
Sir, I feel emptiness emptiness.
Everything is just stopped, she says.
The children had everything.
They were so happy.
The children were happy.
Oh, so now it's just silence.
And small reminders of them.
The names still on each locker.
The Kazan Children's Home is now
a crime scene.
they want us to collect their clothes,
says Elena.
The Russians and collaborators
called in the evening
and said to prepare the children
for the morning.
The busses arrived at eight.
The heartbreaking scenes captured
for Russian
propaganda
shared on a Russian MP's
telegram channel.
The bewildered children
taken from their beloved nurses
in October
transported to Russian occupied Crimea
or Russia itself,
say Ukrainian investigators.
But instead of hiding
this alleged war crime,
Russians advertised it.
Children will be taken to safe conditions
in Crimea, he says.
I will definitely go and visit.
Investigators say
it was part of a premeditated
Russian mission
to take Ukrainian children.
They even targeted hospitals
There was a lot of pressure
by the Russians to take these children.
One too afraid.
It was scary.
Very, very scary.
So much pressure, says all the police.
Twice a day
they demanded
we show them lists of the kids
to take to Russia.
So all NATO came up with
an extraordinary deception.
They had orphans in the ICU.
It would unique.
And they forged medical assessments
saying healthy children
were severely sick.
They even faked
an emergency ventilation, she says.
We understood that
the Russians and collaborators
would not forgive us, she says.
We knew
there would be serious retribution.
We understood this.
But they took the risks
and managed to save children.
And the critical care nurse took it
a step further.
Tatiana says she fell in love
with one of the orphaned children.
She worked desperately
to keep the child off the list.
How are you?
Now she's adopting Kira.
Nice to meet you.
We met them at home.
A Ukrainian mom with her treasured
Ukrainian child.
Kira
Kira is almost ready to walk.
What does she mean to
She means everything to me.
Says Tatiana.
The editing is not just.
I don't even know, to be honest.
I can't imagine my life without Kira.
Hmm.
just awful.
War has given her a precious gift.
So sickening to see this.
David McKenzie joins us now from Ukraine.
From what you've been hearing,
how else have kids
been taken out of Ukraine
and into Russia?
Well, Anderson,
they've been taken like this
in the most egregious way.
But if you see how they do it
so brazenly, openly
in front of the cameras,
in busses, like this from an orphanage,
the Russians didn't seem to care.
They seemed like
they were thinking
they were doing the right thing.
They also took them from parents,
coerced them.
Sometimes parents
gave them willingly
to go to Russian reeducation camps,
summer camps, they called it.
President
Zelensky says that up to 15,000 children
taken in those kind of camps.
In the most serious cases,
like the one
we reported on,
there are many hundreds,
perhaps thousands.
And it's
these kind of cases, Anderson,
that the prosecutor
is looking at very closely and in Kherson,
all those children who have gone well,
they've ended up in occupied Crimea
or Russia,
some of them already
adopted to Russian parents, given
Russian citizenship
in a way losing their Ukrainian identity.
The Ukrainians have no idea
how they will get them back
during this awful war
and even post this war when it ever ends.
The prosecutor is looking at this
to arrest Putin and his chief
adviser on these issues,
whether they ever get them to justice.
Well, that remains to be seen.
Anderson, Kinsey, I appreciate it.
Thank you.